Marshall Faulk joining us on the program
joining us from Mexico where he's
working with Ezekiel Elliott to keep him
in shape get him in better shape ready
for week one are you planning a marsh
how are you I'm curious is where is his
eco Elliot now if there was if we were
playing this weekend and he was in camp
ready to go would he be able to play
this week and play at a high level play
yes play at a high level yes but I would
say you possibly run the risk as any
player would who was not in game
condition shape if you tried to play him
the workload that the Cowboys use him I
don't think he could he could he then
not form that he could go out do the
things that we were accustomed to seeing
him do for a whole game what is your job
with Ezekiel Elliott are just just game
getting it getting them ready for game
getting ready for a game pretty much I
don't I don't let me let me clear I
don't have a job I'm here to just put
him through simulate game action um
do things that violent get you ready
physically to be in condition it's
different if you could do if you played
football you've been around football you
understand a running back job it's just
different it's kind of it's hard to
simulate the contact
yeah but repetition of plays under the
duress of a clock and and and sometimes
how pink often and you're using energy
kind of different it's not just straight
line running it's a it's a it's
different it's different types of
conditioning that you have to do and
that's what I'm putting him through I'm
doing the things that that allowed me to
play whole games things that I did in
offseason things that I did in season
when I when I didn't when I wasn't
playing
say in the preseason to make sure that
come week one I know I'm gonna be ready
if I did these things I know that if it
came down to it at the end of the game I
was going to to be strong enough to help
give us a chance to win the game why
Cabo
it's remote enough we can control who
gets in and out de marte the property
that we're at or King Johnny and his his
staff they take care of us well and we
don't we don't have to deal with you're
not sending anybody to Cabo
I just don't think Kimsey gonna go that
far to see exactly what the workouts are
like I mean you can get a little past
that 30-mile zone and it's kind of hard
to get stuff done but it's worked before
for him and he enjoys being down here it
puts him in the right frame of mind he's
not going to the grocery store here from
the cowboy fan all he's messing up their
fantasy football team you know I'm
guessing Marshall that Zeke is not going
to the grocery store in Cabo either he's
probably has a guy who does that now you
actually would be telling you that was
good wait what were you going to tell me
that was good this is why you are being
tracked with how much conversation do
you have with Zeke about contract stuff
none zero
you don't care doesn't do me any good
you know I'm just here to make sure that
when he's done things carry his business
and the Cowboys are done taking care of
their business so that he's he's in the
best shape possible outside of hitting
so to play that's all that's it the
whole contract issue I don't even I
don't even allow amiss
to bring it up after that as a matter of
fact of the otters with you it's not
even a topic that we talk about it but
this is football we hit the field we
talk field when we put down are we
having dinner and we're having lunch or
or just shoot we're actually talking
football game plan and game management
how to how to conserve energy how to
stay on the field and make sure because
you never know when my check now might
be in a big play or when that handoff
could be could be the big play being
being more serviceable those are the
things that we talk about he's a Hall of
Famer Marshall Faulk he is helping Zeek
Elliot stay in shape get ready for we
assume first week of the regular season
when they face the Giants are you
planning on is he planning on that is
that your time frame B of he's got to be
ready by this date if he's going to be
playing in that opening weekend you know
I haven't had that conversation with
rocky rocky arsenault is easy yeah I
have a rocky Arsenal and I we haven't
talked about exactly the time frame and
and what what they what they would like
to see happen but I know for me it's you
know I just want to make sure that the
days that he's with me that I'm
maximizing my opportunity to get him as
close to game shape as possible and
whenever that date is I want to make
sure that he's done as much as he could
possibly do to make sure that his
responsibilities on the field to his
teammates he's able to fulfill it can
you pass the phone to Zeke and just you
know tell him I just want to say hello
do anything to you but I'm not okay
would you clarify what you said to Rich
Eisen about dak Prescott um here's what
I thought I said if you have a
quarterback in today's economy of
football and you give him a hundred
million dollars and let's say he's done
with that has done with he's earned that
to get paid that because this is them
this is how the market is going
nobody's resetting the quarterback
market or holding it back they're just
allowing the cousin they're allowing a
Jimmy Garoppolo to just go out and hey
you're next man up get some extra money
money like their Aaron Rodgers or Tom
Brady yeah they're just a lot they're
just allowing that but when it comes to
the running back
it's like long now letting on got to get
lesson it's about who's better now now
it's about production I don't even
understand that thought process but I
said this if you're a quarterback you
give him a hundred million dollars and
he doesn't take you to the promised land
then he's just like the rest of those
bum that's making all this money not
doing anything because what happens
after you get that hundred million
dollars now you might have veil of gore
leaving meaning you might have your
right tackle leave and all you might not
be able to put eight is be fair to pass
rusher all you might your team you
cannot afford to take care the rest of
your team
what kind of quarterback do you think
dak Prescott is when Zeke is in there is
he a top-ten quarterback yes yes he is
and and let me make sure that they hear
this I said because they only heard the
import I said doc should give his money
just like everybody else we are going to
see if when it comes to DAC or deshaun
Watson or when it can is it just next
man up or they're gonna try to scale it
back then I've been arguing that that we
need to have a a separate set of
contracts for running backs that
position because you know maybe that
rookie deal that they shouldn't have
them on a four-year with an option deal
I I just think at that position because
I I look at what will happen with say
Quan Barkley what I would have done with
Le'Veon Bell or Christian McCaffrey I'm
gonna load you up for five years I'm
gonna run you ragged and then I'm gonna
move on to the next running back who I'm
gonna bring in at a cheaper price I just
get the feeling and it's not fair to
that position and that
that position alone well if you think
about this and I'm not telling another
man money but if you think about what
what Jalen Rick did and what he got
compared to when Zeke had done and what
he is asking for it's not even close
it's not close well white why did you
think they drafted they drafted a first
round a gherkin and I'm back in the
first round last year if they thought so
much in Jalen
I mean you dropped another ball back in
the first round
should he be the highest-paid running
back should Marsh to the Zeke get more
beggarly if the Cowboys believe about
their their engine is number 21 and how
they are built and I've heard him say
that because the best running back in
the league they you need to pay him like
that
Jerry is is the best owner I mean he's
one of if not the best honor in our
league and we know Jerry does everything
that matched everything he does is push
class can't match the best why when it
comes okay and Zeke he want to pay him
to suck at us I understand that final
question for you Marshall if I talk to
you in two weeks
are you still training Zeke Elliott in
Cabo I believe this Cowboys roster is
probably the most talented talented
roster that that that they put together
and a very long time and and they are
one of the handful of teams in the NFC
that that legitimately has a chance at
getting to the Super Bowl and an hour
and I believe those chances are far
greater risk with 21 back there yeah you
know I think the kid has been great the
Apollo kid I think he's done great I
think he's been serviceable but I just
want I want people you know we dispute
great they look great with James Connor
last year and he did he was doing a
great job but it's different you know
it's different when there's a guy back
there that people understand when they
want before they even play the game on
Monday when they decide to break the
team down you know you game plan your
game plan is that you know you know
there's guys that you just have your
number up with guys with a circle alone
there's guys with two circles around
them that's where you really pay
attention to this guy all right I'll
leave you with this the best running
back in Mexico right now is wait over
you and your prime or Zeke right now
well you just asked me right now I mean
you know I just change and I'll be
honest with you if I was his size with
his feet playing this game at they play
today I think he did all right in your
size Marsh I did I did but you gotta
understand what they were able to do to
us I mean I mean ah man oh yeah the loss
of caution and I could play with they
will just be you can inflict some damage
on somebody yes yes have fun there and
hopefully you're not there too much
longer and tell tell tell Ozzy to keep
fighting the good fight there Gerry old
Jerry will eventually come to come
around he'll tell rocky and and Zeke
that Jerry says hello and we really need
him if he can get in as soon as possible
okay I'm gonna make sure I don't know if
I can
Thank You Marshall that's Marshall Faulk
he's a hall-of-famer for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]